what's the reality of being married as a
power couple you know what's so funny is
everybody says it's really hard Chris
and I kind of look at each other every
day we're like best part of my day but
one of the most incredible things I
think when you find another human who is
striving for something is you really can
track on what's going on in your lives
and there's a lot you can share at least
from my perspective if I was with a man
who wasn't working very hard in a job
it's harder for us to be on the same
page and I end up having to talk with a
lot of other people about the thing I'm
obsessed on all day long the trophy wife
thing never really made sense to me what
would you talk about do you guys just
look at each other all day